Nguyên trong khò hàng của nhà thuốc lông yーバo thành đường,
lực lượng chức năng phát hiện lượng lượng thuốc đồng dược chưa tăng ý lưu hành chỉ giá con một phải thám tỷ đồng.
Ngày 20 chiến tháng 6, phong cạnh sắc kinh tế công an thành phố Hồ Chí Minh,
bắt nguyễn đăng thuốc, năm 2019 và nguyễn đăng thải, sống Mỹ sảo tuổi,
chủ nhà thuốc lông yーバo thành đường để điều tra hành vi sản xuất, buồn bán hàng cấm.
Mở giọc điều tra đường dây sản xuất, tiêu thuốc thuốc đồng dược cấm,
huy mỗi lưỡn tại nhiều điều phương, cạnh sát khỏi hợp sở y tế thành phố Hồ Chí Minh,
khám sát cơ sở thuốc bảo thành đường, thu dữ lượng lượng thuốc điều chỉ bệnh ra liệu chưa được các phép liều hành.
Cơ quan điều tra sát định từ tháng 3 năm hành hình không trọng hành mi tư đến nay,
hành người này đã đưa ra thị trường số thuốc có tổng giả trị hơn mười tỉ đồng.
Nha chức trách đang tiếp tục truy sẽ tất đẹp điều thuốc, làm gió nguồn cùng người liệu và vai trọc của những người liên quan.
Bảo thành đường, là thương hiệu hiệu học của chuyên hoạt động nhiều năm, chuyên khám chữ bệnh và phân phối các sản phẩm đông dược đến nhiều tình thành.